[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur la chaîne
parlementaire de l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
s'est pas trop fort sans bienvenu merci
de nous retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro
le parlement hebdo
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur lcp il est
13 heures
où va la france c'est le thème du débat
du jour pantois tous ravis de vous
retrouver à la une de ça vous regarde ce
soit ce soir myriam on va parler musique
j'arrive tout de suite clément mairie
vous êtes salle des quatre colonnes
l'ambiance est un peu électriques sur ce
texte ah oui je pomme je suis fier
d'être un saint pe dicale mes chers
collègues armes égales en 2010 j'avais
levé la séance à je vous préviens je
suis il vous plaît arrêtez pousser des
cris
or
[Musique]
peut-on encore parler d'un moment de
vérité aujourd'hui lorsqu'il est
question d'une interview politique c'est
la question posée aujourd'hui dans ce
débat doc vous êtes bien vous êtes
vraiment bien sur lcp la chaîne qui dit
on voit la politique en grand le contrat
c'est le nom de cette émission bonjour à
tous voilà l'idée d'entamer cette
journée avec nous dans politique matin
alors évidemment vous vous demander mais
qu'est ce qu'elle trafic est ce que on
fait une émission sur les fringues ou
pas pas du tout nous on fait des confiné
bienvenue à robin à l'émission qui
parcourt les archives de l'ina en tenue
de gala c'est une chaîne de qualité
d'associé content de de la rejoindre
[Musique]
on
c'est un vrai fan de la chaîne
parlementaire j'ai commencé avec la
commission outreau j'ai écouté à peu
près les deux tiers des débats et depuis
je les écoute tous les après midi au
bureau l'écoutent parce que maintenant
je commence à reconnaître les uns et les
autres en étant hors du lingot j'aborde
us et vous
[Rires]